so
Oh dear traveller, you look exhausted, you need a pint and I'll stoke the heart for you.
Oh dear traveller, with your weary feet and looking your eyes, why don't you come on down
to meet Tavern and together we will make the greatest tavern known to man.
Mummy, what is this name you are calling me for?
I am the Tavern Master today.
I am fucking exhausted, but with Jesus, they've got a fucking difficulty mod.
And bloody Tavern Master, what's going on here?
You offer other services far, fair bar made, why it depends how many gold coins you'd like to
part with?
Right, relax, it is easier to make money and disasters are much less dangerous.
Normal, everything is balanced, this is how the game was meant to be played.
Welcome to your tavern, traveller.
Wait, well welcome to my tavern, traveller.
You will be in charge of managing and growing your business.
Oh irish, I was trying to do, oh no, I was trying to hop it in.
Oh shit it is irish, wait hold on.
Master Frodo, great job, you can also rotate the camera by holding the right mouse button
and moving the mouse around, albeit the tavern, the tavern doesn't look like a tavern at all,
that's never been irish today, one wall is missing, there are no doors and no windows,
let's fix that, oh dear, well we can't be having that, but I'd like to build a wall,
okay I'll build a wall, very good, I've now added a door, fantastic, okay, and a window,
we need to let in that natural light. Someone stole our wall, you ain't the,
the music got our head in mid air, great job, now let's buy some tables and benches,
we need it for the patrons, we only have one table in our tavern right now, that will be enough,
okay I agree with that, please let us commence forth, because that is a thing, you placed this
prop on the wrong position, I'm getting in trouble for putting down a chair wrong, show lights,
one of the benches is not inside any light range, let's light a candle to fix that,
wait what, you have to put this item next to a pillar, on a pillar, great job, how many hours,
I got like five hours, oh maybe four actually, it took me to the end of the video for the
sleep, that means I technically got four hours, I'm feeling like a wary traveler, but that's all
right, we can still run our business, as you can see, are here, I still have my,
my, my ale, which also just happens to have honey in it, and milk, and tea, that's my ale,
only four, I got two, who's this bar wench, I am, what would my bar name be,
great job, I don't know what my name would be, oh honey mead, that would be my bar wench name,
hi there traveler, my name's honey mead, because I'm known for consuming honey,
and also that might, great job, now that we have enough seats for our guests,
next up would be to buy beer and serve it, all right, we go into this tab, to buy beer we should
go to the bar first, click on the bar to open the menu, we currently have only water to,
we are not serving water, to serve the beer we first have to fill the barrel, click,
max refill, close, back, now what, great job, we now have plays for people to sit, we have drinks
to serve, final thing missing is to hire a staff, oh I get to hire you, open the staff
off it, are you playing, wait where are you, what are you, are you Isaac, because of the
binding of it, is that a reference, oh sugar, what, tray, mood decreases 20% sworn,
what, is this like actually statistics, can carry eight drinks at a time, well,
when he is his line, carry four drinks, can carry eight drinks, when he is his tell in
fibrinos, hold on a minute, did you make the sip, no I didn't, I'm making it today,
I had to do friggin work again, ah, also I completely forgot I spoke in my newest video,
I was checking the comments and someone was like no talking, has talking one minute in
and I was like what, I didn't talk in this roleplay, I literally blew the ears like because
I remember recording it and I was just going ear to ear, blow, blow, blow, blow over and over again
until you know I hit the 20 minute mark, ah, and then someone time stamped it and I went
did that tickle and I'm like oh for fuck's sake shut up, I've literally like put in the title
and they talking and all that and I'm like ah, so I'm gonna have to put, I'm gonna have to take
out no talking in the title like a good girl, right, Isaac actually just means reflin, Hugo,
Redford and Jack, unless, no, we'll do Isaac, I want to stick to my gun, hire Isaac, no shit,
wait what, you should hire a waitress now right, ah, why are do waitresses literally needle,
gain experience, Annabelle, Matilda, Judy, you carry four drinks, gain experience twice as last, sure, sure
whoa, what, take out, wait, hold on a minute, there's Uber Eats in Middle Earth, take out,
all right, okay, we've prepared, I don't know if you could just sniff it,
okay, I'm gonna actually, you know what, I'm actually gonna sniff like the title right now,
there, and then no one can complain that if I can talk, there, and then I'm gonna, oh,
you know what, I'll gaslight the guy, how about that, hold on, wait, wait, wait, hold on,
right, so someone said no talking, talks in the first 60 seconds, oh, I'm sorry,
sorry, this is, oh, I'm sorry, I, I don't think I said it wasn't talking, hope it's okay though,
and you were still able to enjoy this video in general, thank you for at least checking me out,
there, I'm being so nice and humble, I'm being so, and then I'll do, just to make it even smoother,
I'll do a little emoji if I can, of the, of the, oh, sugar, right, I'll just do the cat face, why
not, oh no, no, no, don't do it face, right, oh, I'm sorry, I didn't know, I said it wasn't talking,
hope it's okay though, and you were still able to enjoy this video in general, thank you for at least
hearing me out, I actually did that, that's terrible, and before he's like literally listening to the
live stream right now, and he's like what, what are you on about, we just pulled a little prank on him,
what, no talking, never heard of it, um, right, I've got my cup of tea, actually I need to check
Marshmallows, um, fucking, tried to put Azir's trailer up yesterday for her doughnuts on, and I
think because she got a warning for eating a cookie, it's not gonna play on her live stream,
so what was supposed to happen is when you click on Azir's live stream,
it would play her little trailer, and I got a really tasteful trailer, but I think we're just
gonna have to upload it in general, which is fine, it's not a problem, I'll put some ad money on it,
um, eating a cookie is forbidden, so she was eating a cookie, but her face was cropped off on the
bottom, and YouTube was like, hmm, this person eating a cookie is, hmm, how do you say popcorn,
and we're like, no, and argued it, and they're like yeah, this is popcorn, and we're like,
ah, okay, we'll go kill ourselves, so like, YouTube just, I give up with even trying to,
like, if they get, I just give up on trying to get it removed, or anything of that nature,
um, Shawnee, I think you should have breakfast with Liz at the start of every stream, and drink a
tea, make it a habit, just 50 minutes of company nutrition, we can get really good food and eat
together, what the heck, that's so sweet, Traveller, sorry, I forgot how it just sound like it was
all this, YouTube didn't, to be fair, Azura is popcorn, her voice,
oh wait, why am I typing in, sorry, I meant to type in Azura Delay, and I started typing in
and I'm just gonna check, it's a dang trailer, so where, where is it, I swear to God, I'm pretty
sure it doesn't work, 12 hour donut phone click, nah, the trailer doesn't play,
see you YouTube, see you wet leaf art, but I'll upload her trailer shortly,
but she's eating a cookie, not popcorn, you know what, you got me there, yeah,
oh, I just realised the staff were outside waiting, oh, there's people,
oh my gosh, we like, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, wait, we need to change the name of the town,
I was gonna call it the dragon, the green dragon, because that's what it is in a Hobbiton,
the prance in Pony's Bree, mummy, they used to be a super awesome barmaid town called the green
dragon, it was Hobbit doing this, oh, what the heck, I'm so dumb, the start of the downfall is
Ronnie Wheeler getting Ronnie Gaslight in a random guy, mark it in the finger on the monkey
paw curls, because I said, because I removed no talking from the title of the video, oh that's
terrible, honestly, mummy I'm mad, wait, why are you mad, I had a cup of plastic containers
in the freezer filled with plain and not rotten pork fillings, what, and they got, last week my
roommate ate the third of my cheese bags without asking, I got the smallest bag on sale for two
years old, holy shite bag, you're back, are you squiddling me right now, oh no, oh shit, I don't remember
what's going on with any songs, oh, hey, there's no lady cuttles here,
only honey, uh, ale, ale honey, honey ale, thank you groomed by vealer, oh, um, no, I have to thank
you by name, fuck you, I'm right, you're wrong, thank you, thank you vealer for the super chat,
I didn't, I like, I registered but I didn't register until the words came out my mouth,
I'm sorry, but at the same time, thank you for the super chat, um, pour a glass of your finest
ale, sorry I just said the word but, we've prepared everything, I'm so not awake right now, hold on,
let's drink the tea first, have a look, oh, got my honey bum, I'm right, you're wrong, yeah, it's
the Matilda thing, he's like, I'm right, you're wrong, I'm big, you're small, I can't remember
the rest of it, no, I have a confession to make, I have been listening to some of your ASMR from
YouTube while at work and have gone to the bathroom to thank, oh, good morning to you too,
Riefland, I'm glad I can help, I think your training is starting to work out real and true,
how many hours did you sleep? No, no, I am, I am, sorry, I'm rubbing my face,
I have in the mild exhaustion, so please, please do not be surprised when the membership stream
turns into a yap fest, because that's what naturally happens, I do not have my brain
powered even mustard, the thought of conjuring up a script for a collab, right, got any liquor,
I have beer, okay, we've prepared everything needed for the travellers to start coming in,
before we unpause this game, let's see how you can unlock new stuff for the paver and click
the research button, upgrades are rescheduled, oh, nope, that's not that word, upgrades are
researched by serving different types of guests, types of guests, what are we doing,
a bit of cheeky profiling here, what's going on, and you can see the cost of research on the left
side for it, for kitchen, we need to serve 25 commoners, whoa, what in the futilism is going on here,
right, our only option right now is to research a kitchen, so click on the button,
right now what, oh, I read that a little too fast, oh, read that a little too fast and get
sure, sure, right, number of guests per day tell you how many people will come into your
cavern on average every day, buy decorations and upgrade your cavern to increase that number,
decorations, okay, my final tip to you is that you watch out if there is enough space to sit,
if all the seats are taken, buy more tables and benches, well can I buy them like now,
I can't get, I don't know, are people going to be self-conscious if they sit at a little table
and upgrading our capacity already, shite, we're out of money, I never thought it was far ahead,
well I tried my best, we can now fit more guests because of the seats at least,
right, and then beer and water, cuminers, oh my god, and you come cuminers, I need 25 of you,
oh my god, oh, hold on a minute, we've got a little camera rotation if I really want to get that,
oh, what's that, is that an elf, it is, it's a nun, oh my god, a sheebie through through,
are you a ranger of some sort, oh look at that serve, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, look at this,
and you come to me tavern, and you come, and you come,
and yeah that's right, how many people, elf are Jen too,
maybe, maybe, you might like one of the,
you might like one of the ears on one of the girls in particular, if elves are your thing,
am I confirming elves, nope that's not what I said, I said you might like the ears on some girl,
that's all I'm saying, don't shoot the messenger, I'm not the one who comes up,
I'm fucking off the dev team, okay, the only thing I do is I approve the design, okay,
and I deny too because I was like fuck this, but then I approved,
I was,
knife ears, wait what, what is knife ears,
can you teach me something new, knife ears, is that a thing or are you deceiving me,
and I'm falling for your ruse, wait how, what, a tavern knife ears, first thing that comes up,
reddit dnd, how racist is it to call an elf a knife ear, is this, is this mythological racism
in 4k, what, am I, what, is derogatory to elves, elves don't exist, that's hilarious,
wait I need to read that debate, I'm not even kidding, what is that debate, hold on, opening up
that right now, right, how racist is it to call an elf a knife ear, so one of my players plays an
elvish rogue and they're going to be entering a large city and I thought it would be fine,
find the people they're not the most hospitable to, I don't see an issue, racial tension,
what is going on in dnd, I thought, oh my god, wait she's not clean enough after the patrons,
or is everyone just getting absolutely wasted, am I being a dumb dumb,
okay that was good, yeah I guess I can only have a certain amount of quests a day,
god I'm learning, what's going on with you dnds, dnds, she didn't know about the knife,
how is that, oh you've got pointy ears almost like a knife,
that's a slur in my fantasy game, what, what, oh your ears look like they resemble something,
okay what, you elf derogatory, literally,
mommy you can't say that, wait am I getting cancelled because of fantasy dnd and I can't
comprehend how, I thought racial tension was also part of fantasy, I thought it was sexual
tension, I thought in dnd you kind of hump each other a bit, you can't trust the knife
ears, they'll stab you in the back, he cut old me knife ears, I'm literally shaking right now,
honestly I'm absolutely, you're gonna get cancelled on elv twitter, rock and stone,
you're not going home, yeah don't worry about me, I'ma be in the minds of moria, that's all I'm
saying, that's all I think about them pointy ear delves, I'll be in the minds of moria, okay,
mommy bye, gnomes keep out entries, save me a diamond, no, oh no, wait can I change the name now,
yes, oh my god, what was it, the green dragon inn, even though we don't have any beds,
the green dragon inn, and you come, okay, we made good money,
if you think, oh, if you think this is bad, you should play dragon age, fantasy racism is off the
charts, also take my super cherry, oh yoinkers, my cherry nose, thank you draco,
welcome to the green dragon inn, no knife ears, hold on wait can I first say no though sister,
honestly I could not have expected, oh, well,
no, no that's because I invested in fernet ear, right, that's because of fernet ear,
oh my god I'm bossed on day one, man, why did I start a business, I'm already bossed,
angry customers, no no one left angry, that's good, oh my god we have lemonade in middle
earth, just a little bit of sugar, a little bit of lemon and some water, oh yeah, okay, okay,
uh let's do beer, we're still cool, okay, okay, not gonna, I'm gonna say something controversial
actually, or, oh, I mean money, I forgot about wages, I forgot about wages, I will say I actually
really like this game already off the bat, it's so cosy and cute and uh yeah, I can see myself
getting my dick paid, you did make a little look at refills versus income, look at refills versus
income, refills income, close enough, okay, there's plenty of beer to go around though,
what's this one, it will be done before, yeah okay, yeah, drinks and then clean them, we can
raise their wages, unfortunately I can't afford for that yet, for now feudalism, tomorrow maybe
actually, 90% of new businesses fail on the first day, wait did they fail on the first year normally,
the first account of lemon ages, in the 12th century Egypt,
after your shift, I'll make you into a mess on the bar table, excuse me traveler, that's an
appropriate conduct, get out, get out, get out pointy ears, out, out me in, thank you very
lord for the super chat, capitalism 90% of gamblers, let's finish this tea,
not paying your employees, is that some kind of veal or tight, real and true, remainder, it's
contracted, that total income chart is gonna be like my savings after the donathan,
a cow car, you better be teasing, I'm gonna fart on your eyelashes, if the lawyer had a tavern,
which of the girls would be the best bartender, everyone's vote in the chat for your oh she,
now I'm gonna say something controversial, because of AC's pause she can't grip things properly,
so I'd maybe put AC on cleanup duty, like instead of like picking items up to take off tables to
take to the back, she would just scoop it up like in her hands like she was hugging it like a present,
that's how she would do it, AC I'm guard you, oh that's right you need a, you need a thingy,
right I would put AC right here, oh no no it has to be on the inside sorry, I'd put AC right here
because she looks menacing and scaly, and then I would, I mean Sheevy would have to serve, I think
Azura would be in the corner like singing as entertainment, Sheevy would be a waitress,
Mercy would be a chopping up the food in the back because obviously she's got the most knife
experience, Emi, would Emi, I think Emi, I would put Emi on entertainment as well, so Azura
is in the corner singing for those of them who don't really want any hype entertainment,
whereas I think Emi would be like a teasing bar mate that goes around and makes sure you're having
a good time and then ad be on the bar, I don't think that would go rather well, I don't know,
maybe I'm biased, I think that would work out, hold on a minute girls, I got a backup plan if
everything goes to shit, now hold on a minute, hey thank you for the super chat, I want any
trouble, Emi is just there, hi Johnny, how do you travel her? Wouldn't Azura be a nice chef?
I feel like Azura has so much appeal being seen though, I wouldn't want her hidden away,
and like Mercy would be in her element cutting up steaks and all that and being like ah that's
a nice chunky, oh wait that's not what she sounds like at all, oh that's a nice chunky cut of steak,
I'm so sorry Mercy, I'll practice your voice one do, one do,
Veiler Tavern Art when? Stop, I'm working with this artist right now and she is like so down for
any freaking like thing I present her, she's like so happy, that needs to like finish that,
oh it's Lemonade's barge, so I can't actually even do anything with it, yeah I'm currently working
with this artist and she's so nice and lovely, and I like explained one of the projects I wanted
to do with her, and she's like yeah I'm down, I'm like oh shit what the fuck, because there was
loads of work, like there's a lot of work going on behind the scenes, Azura, oh no I can't say that,
maybe tomorrow I can say it, no it's not a big deal, it's a good thing but I don't want to ruin this
surprise, Johnny trying not to ruin anything for Veiler, challenge impossible, right congratulations
chocolate, that was like a weird mix of Scottish vendors, hold on a minute, congratulations on
unlocking the kitchen, here's about 800 bonus, do we have enough money to, money to build it,
step one go to the shop, buy a kitchen counter shelf, plate and a crate, hire a chef, wait for
customers to order food, where do I put the kitty in though, where are you, no sorry dumbass,
nope that's wrong, okay this is, how or where do I put the kitchen,
obliet, wait am I being daft, or no please don't click that, I have already used up the room that
was available to me, that was just so exciting, okay I am gonna have to move the kitchen to here,
and I like to put people out, you can't buy new props because some props are overlapping,
make sure all the tiles are green on the floor, oh they don't let you like,
right how do I get rid of this then, right no, and storage, no okay good, and then
uh are you squidding me right now, sometimes,
how are you, wait there must have been like a better way to do this, and I'm just very small
brains, I'm not sure that's right at all, in order to upgrade this item, you know I want to move it
like here, are they gonna be able to access that, thank you the booty lord, you're on the ram ranch,
18, we're gonna research seven, wait you have to research more guests a day,
musicians a zero, oh you can do takeaway from that, oh how interesting,
special events, you click the event button, click plus, choose the event and click confirm it,
do we want more money, I assume if we do all of this, more plants, stairs,
and then we can have a sleepy area, and then I can take the reef ones that get to drunk up there,
for no particular reason at all, can't you just make a new room, oh I never even,
that didn't even occur to me, I, and what is known as dumb, very dumb actually,
know that you mentioned that, know that you, don't be mad at me, you're in my way,
it's a learning exactly, all right so what I should have done is remove these walls, and
just done that,
it's rather expensive, right if we just be cheeky,
if we just be cheeky and put down the seats that were already there,
I mean they're now sitting on grass, I'm not sure how happy they're gonna be,
100 for a freaking candlestick, excuse me, oh I didn't put that right, okay hold on,
I'm just moving it over closer, because yeah that, how about we do that, yes, I'm learning,
I'm learning, okay so now we have a functional kitchen, kind of, no we need to hire, I must hire
a chef, hire a chef, wait oh I can hire a new chef, the table's not lined up, I know, I saw it,
I'm just like oh no, I think someone's not gonna like that, arthritis, arthritis, Gail Reeves,
oh my god if Keanu is the the movie we watched, speed, skill for dessert, skill for main course,
skill for soups, I need someone, oh you're the best at soups, okay soups, yes, make
focus, focus, there's a pizza on your focus, oh they're raging, they're leaving, oh they're
no having it, what do you mean you don't want to sit on the grass, what do you mean you don't
want to come in, where's the roof, there's no roof, we're just at the one, okay no, so they
don't mind sitting on the grass, no they don't seem to bother, that's fine, although I assume the
further the tables the longer people are gonna complain because she needs to like get their orders
and go back and then go moo moo moo, or nor, it's keanu, our moony, our symmetry, is that really,
I think once we get more moola, I'll like make the tables closer as a chef, I'm just checking
this works, I need to, I need to like, what, total what, buy, higher adventurers to get ingredients,
right, so we do have stuff in store to make moola, there are orders, no refilling, we're not
starting that, you goofy giver, does the chef need something to cook good with, that's what I thought
but it seems like he just prepares it, has me thinking my boba,
okay, so what do we need, we need candle lights to spruce the place up a bit so it lights the
press and apparently disasters can happen which make, okay that's much better, oh wait no we got
800 from the down thing, total seats, average capacity, average action, serving drinks,
taking the order, preparing the food, serving the food, I only like just started anyway,
right okay let's, I mean we already expanded our welcome to the green dragon in with one window,
that's all you're getting and no more, you don't deserve natural sunlight,
someone said stop, adventuring reeflings we must gather for a moment, yeah apparently I need
to send you a way to get stuff, okay so he grabs it from a chest, okay but he still seems to have,
like the beer's still full as well, we did that eons ago, it looks like water never runs out,
like at all, but the beer does, the beer does, okay he's, oh no he can clip through this which
it makes him speed running, um do we need to hire, what do we do, we got lemonade so we'll do
guess because that gives us more money and then lemonade, and then refill it, oh no I don't have
enough money to refill the food, okay every time I make money I'm just gonna hit max refill until
it's full, if they can't see the sunrise they wouldn't want to leave, oh my gosh wait that
must be a tactic, that has to be, oh well the missus isn't waiting for me to come back because
I can't see the sunlight, I don't need to touch grass as long as I can touch mommy, oh wait I'm
not supposed to say it, I'm sorry, but yes Mercy, Emi and AC have had older, why does it keep making
that noise, oh because, oh if it, oh because it's based on number of guests served, I'm wondering if
with like, I just want to make sure we're quite stocked up because I'm gonna be jump-scared when
we're not, mommy's serving, why touch grass to go anywhere when mommy is there, yeah okay so
refills cost those purchases, that's fine, that's fine, oh no why are you sad,
point,
wait but were you were sad because you could level up, that's interesting so you can like
level up a character, make sure the wheat is not flaked honestly,
this is a cute game honestly, I can see myself like playing this offline,
oh my god, it's a, it's runescape, the wizards outside of Iraq that always killed me when I was a
freaking baby, I heard it is the best thing one will ever taste,
no wait I'm replaying that because I spoke over it like a dumbass, are you squidding me right now,
hey barmaid, do you have some of that scrawny fish soup here, I heard it is the best thing one will
ever taste, oh it's very, it's very um oishi I've heard, very oishi, yes, yes thank you weary traveler
for your interest in scrawny bro, I assure you you will not be disappointed by the flavour, you see
it's made with very secret ingredients that cannot be replicated anywhere else,
yeah,
what do they do, oh he gets them, are they base, are they modelled after Skyrim, no dumbass,
that's just actually how old stuff used to look, quite murky and tangy, I think I'll just have
a water, put gross hair on your chest, gross fur on your knees, potent, actually really potent,
hold on a minute, savoury, full of umami, like most sifa dishes I assure you, I wonder if mommy
has a secret menu, wait are they crying, she's like oh I'm so sad, people starting to get raging,
oh my god I'm in trouble, it's made from scrawny berries, I'm just thinking I like cook myself
in the bath basically and I'm like well are they gonna love this, or to be umami, right,
tall seat 16, customers serve 32, so don't need my seat, angry customers, no one, so I don't need
a new waitress yet, it's when I need a new waitress, that's when I have to start worrying, right,
max refill the beer, max lemonade, and then, oh sugar, okay well maybe I shouldn't have done that,
right um, um um um, I guess on the research if we do take away we get more mula, can't be
fast forward, that's toxic, right start, I did take away, I feel like Uber Eats in Middle
Earth is like the most money you can make on something, because I like the system though,
like even though it's all different tables you can do a thing, oh god she's speeding,
I know I've got it on time, but she is speeding around that, look at her go,
I don't care if it's toxic, I'm drinking it anyway,
this is like simulation run, okay, a wee bit honestly, I think it's cute, I think this is a
very cute game, I mean come on what other tavern would allow, be half on the grass and half on the
wood, you know, it's one of them, I mean no, no, no, I must refrain from my fantasy racism,
which I got to learn about today, mother could we please get floors, sure how on earth I get
floors, upper floor takes with floors, oh it's free, oh I just, I was just making them sit on
grass in general, sorry that was my bad, fantasy, literally that was so that was hilarious, like
just I didn't even know that was a thing, and then just that being the first result, I'm like
what are you even on about, what are you even on about, what are you, what is that,
that's like a trifle, no leaf lovers allowed, mommy can I please have a beer, sure,
look at how successful the business is going, refluence, we're doing it, we're gonna have the
best tavern in all the land, I'm okay, when everyone leaves I'm actually gonna shove the
tables together a lot closer, and then I'm gonna rearrange the kitchen,
I lost money, oh and refills that's fine, okay what I'm gonna do pause, pause, pause, pause,
I am going to move everything like way closer because everything's like half a mile apart,
oh no, I just saw that loss, oh literally, all right okay so tables,
uh you know what, let's, oh my god let's, let's get right into the, oh the table,
maybe this would be really cute for like a layout as well, and there's like different ways you can
sit and stuff, rather than having it all grouped together, I think I might like that more,
so we need to think of the funk suede, would one refling please think of the funk suede,
oh that's too close, um I might a little bit, look, look, come on, come on, this is,
this is all a part of how the game works, it has to be perfect or else what's the point,
right one, and then two, and then a bin, yes, oh my god look at the funk suede, see here when
you enter, yes walk, walk, walk, and then you take a little look to the right, hold on let's go
the full thing, look to the right, you're like yes yes, delicious, you take a little look to the
left, you're like yes right, I'll make my pathway through here, yes yes yes, I like all the ambience,
see, we see, that's how you have to run a business, you have to think like a customer,
you can't think like a business owner, you have to think like a customer, do you understand me,
and I say yes, I think this is nice and a bit more
and then I'll put one table over, oh
can I go, let's see,
oh my god them tunes, them medieval tunes are hitting, first thing in the morning,
right you my kind and noble chef, you keep going in a different order than I ordered,
oh, sorry, oh no wait, I tried so hard not to say that, I tried so, I tried so hard,
but in the end it didn't even matter, so what he's doing is, I'm overlapping, over the fucking light,
what, so if I hold on, mommy's not got a brain, mommy's not got a brain,
go and storage, go and storage, go and more,
can you go somewhere else right now or am I just like perma stuck with a, oh well I'm just perma
it was nice, employees are stationed at, move employees to other locations or fire them,
I don't want to fire them just to move some furniture, hold on a minute game dev, hold on a minute,
well we're just doing it like this then, it's not the most efficient way I know but, oh the
just leave it the way it was, vain, oh you win game, you win,
you can't escape it, just embrace it, no I did so well not saying that,
that was purposefully right, can we line it up,
that was it right, no I missed, I missed, there's a gap, I missed, I missed,
I missed, hurry hurry hurry, hurry go, now wait hold on,
okay there we go, this is, okay and now what we're gonna do, controversial, oh no we're not
because we can't afford to, wait what's this then, it's just a fancier table, we put it in the middle
everyone's like staring at you, all right and then we'll get another, another, another one,
another one, unless, I just put a table of four in the middle, I don't really want to put people
off like that, you know you don't want to be sitting in the middle and everyone's looking at
you, you're like hmmm, okay and then we will put lights over here because we need to
expand, not of money, well I tried okay, I tried and then we'll get like a table and stuff, okay we
have, we have a new table at least, somehow this is probably a lot worse, I'm sure they can handle it,
I'm sure they can handle it, wait what's wrong, why are you so, she also said speed not carrying,
can carry four drinks, make it five then, drinks can be good,
the tavern's coming along pretty nice, I mean we finally got a floor, only took me,
what they have, oh there's a castello,
I didn't even call that, is there only a castello, is that it, we're serving people from the castle,
how was your, oh weary castle workers, how was your shift, was it shite,
we're gonna suffer, the tavern music slaps, well we are going to entertain and come in,
oh I can buy musicians, how do I do that, how do I do that, games, games, wait people wait,
special, another, what is that, fire extinguisher, are you even nervous now,
musicians podium, I assume that's what I'm, maybe,
decoration seats, table kitchen, game, give them, oh my god are you going to station,
this item is not unlocked yet, oh my god I want dandelion leaves outside,
are you squidding me right now, hi Mina, thank you for the extended membership,
hey little sea weed, I hope you're doing well, I am, I'm just a sweepy bee,
but that's not gonna stop me, I'm just too emotional, so what musicians, podium, musicians
podium is used to hire musicians which attract more people to your tavern and make customers
wait for longer before they get angie, okay right hire is or I've got it, I will, I will,
actually I will, there's the red the day boy, and how are we for supplies,
yep there's supplies and stuff, you can go games on your tavern I think so,
I mean she's getting really good though, she's getting skilled up but he's,
oh he can level up to speed, uh drink pouring speed, that makes sense to put up,
chef can just speed for dessert, why no, oh maybe I should even out and do a main course,
okay so everyone's level enough, we're all getting experience, you're even a full-time barista,
I mean I was a waitress, I got to make drinks at my jou, because you don't need
like a tarotificat to pour a drink, so I got to make drinks for people, I don't know if I ever
told this story, I had, okay build a takeout counter so you can attract new customers who
don't want to sit inside but just order and take the food with them, oh just realize you can't see
my cursor, there we go, you can see my cursor now, build a wall with a counter, buy the takeout
counter, buy a packing table, wait for customers to start ordering their food, um yes I served
Japanese customers, it was three Japanese girls and they were using like Google Translate to talk
and they just ordered three hot chocolates and like I got to make them up and all that type thing
and then when I put it down on the table they all went like, they were like, oh my god this is so
precious like because and then like they said thank you in their acts, I was like oh my god, oh my god
I get it now, thank you umi for the red, I promise I have that ASMR, oh wait I might let
say that we have an ASMR class, I may have let the leak, I'm sorry I let the leak, okay okay I
didn't mean it, hi thank you for the redirect, I will very quickly give you that wrench so you
stand out because you need a wrench, oh I just added my own live stream to my watch later list,
that's how much of a panic I'm in right now, oh that's me, please be quiet, um I literally,
okay, not only do I spoil um Veal Ur plans, I also spoil plans I have with people that are
willing to collab with me, oh yeah, but thank you for the read, hi I'm Stronecals, I'm Scottish one
from Veal Ur, you know that company where we're naughty naughties, but we're actually
surprised surprised we're not that naughty on YouTube, except Emi you know she she got a strike
because she let a rat sniff a mic, that's right, I admit it, it's the worst kind of sin possible,
honestly truly, um we're playing a game called a tavern master and obviously I've named it after
the green dragon in because guess what, it's okay lol I have to literally do member stream
silly secrets because I can't keep my mouth shut ever, oh someone who gets it, Emi, Emi it's so
freaking hard, I try so hard not to ruin anything for the girls and all their like surprise and
secrets so I need to be quiet and I'm just sitting here like, like my face is, I'm like that meme where
your face gets red, it's like that guy's face gets red in the meme, I understand it's so hard to be
like snitches, snitches get snitches honestly, oh icicle read as well, hi snowberries, I hope you're
doing well, um I'm playing a game called tavern master, um but Emi is where I can't and redirected
into me and we're just talking about how both of us cannot stop spoiling things, and it's so hard
because it's so exciting when you plan stuff and especially if it's something big like I still
have that secret thing in two months that I can't talk about and I'm waiting for time to fly forward
um I just get so excited to tell people things literally like it's so exciting like planning
something new and being like yeah yeah yeah it's all coming to especially when it comes together
um if you guys didn't know um Emi if you take a cheeky gander on her youtube channel um she
came out with a song um which is absolutely jaw-dropping it was fantastic it was composed it just
was gorgeous so please um check it out it's called endless blue I kid you not listen to it and tell
me you don't feel emotions again okay because that song resurrected me resurrected me I will listen
to it for the first time yesterday I'd seen it in your name for a while Emi on twitter and I was like
yes I will remember to listen to it at some point and I finally got some time to myself and I listened
to it and I was like oh my god so tape in endless blue on youtube right now
salary wait did I say wax oil am I going mental did I say wax and oil for the lights
I have a daily tax on wax understand wax doesn't fall from trees but
what okay we're gonna refill our stockages
if he oh okay we're just gonna buy as much as we can and ah your comment meant so much to me
I was so happy you enjoyed it put my whole my whole ass tail into the song damn straight
if no you mate is a shark you have a tail and a shark right if I'm not mistaken
but you might be another aquatic animal with a tail I was getting so nervous if I messed up the
lore of I'm like oh god but yes um I am a whale shark so I'm the largest shark okay there you go
there you go Emi also does they smart if you're in the business for it so don't be shy be nice to
my friends replaying tax on wax that's whack
well I was a refund stroke not mine so I procedures make more customers
from buying decorations okay so I actually oh I'm not doing research
there are no fire extinguishers on floor zero
um say no more why yes of course I know what a fire extinguisher is 50 coins which I don't have
oh so now you credit the refunds yeah when the when the joke goes down badly
how good is the food you serve here at the green dragon there's this quality
establishment over in Isengard whose salted pork is particularly good
are we at max capacity oh hmm we might be at max ascent whoa whoa stop being miserable
because I don't promote you even though I don't pay you any extra money
tips minus two what speed climbing stairs I've not even put anything into that I'll
just put speed randomly in the speed but it's drawing I'm going to go grab someone
yes I'm glad you had a good stream please rest up I hope we have a wonderful stream thank you
hope you had a wonderful weekend we will leak secrets all later we will leak oh whoa I
didn't even know I could do that I can make bread now fantastic gorgeous
what's going on here what am I trying to achieve where I'm trying to build the fire
extinguisher because the game is making me worried because it's like you don't have right
how about no we can't hear about near where where's the best place to put this I don't
know oh so that's allowed to go on the light but the other thing isn't right music that's massive
um
I feel like it has this actually has to go at the back of the
oh that's big
eight songs plus seven guess wait 10 seconds more for on the floor
have I got an extra 50 quid a day I don't even think I've got enough money for that I think I
would have to buy the takeout window first I think I'll extend the back here and then make
the takeout window because that is rough
furthest in gonna make it far away in the corner
finally our scottish cuttlefish was playing a game for her just have a good one ah it's a good game
grabbing some chinese get some sweet sour rip well we don't serve sweet sour ribs in middle
sorry that's that's not for that's not what we do here we do oh my god how do I increase my
money sold and earned is it really just up in the drinks I mean wine
you get these special guests by organi what no that's not right wine I guess wine and ale
it's a 75 persons okay so the more variety and what I offer the more I'm going to get
all right I think what my objective will be then is just to fill this place with seats everywhere
doesn't matter where I'm just a min maxim the seats right now do we serve fried elf ears
you can say that quality of customers improve with expensive drinks I think that might be what it is
um because I'm enjoying I don't know if I should get a big ass tea oh my god yes I want that right
we're gonna get that table next I want big big grand duest table okay
that's what we're doing next just seats to stare at the people you literally like
right now there's I think there's enough distractions like going on so people aren't
just staring at each other why does this the decorations that's going to change everything
wait I only have rough that's it a rug no I'm not making the tavern is an introverse hell literally
you have to pass everyone I'll mix so I'll do is I'll do that long table and then I'll do like
those two tables like the weird ones here around the musician and then kind of spice it up a bit
you know you oh wait I need to put a staircase somewhere if we wish to expand you know I'll
deal with that later that's future me's problem right now I'm just chilling I'm just chilling have
a good time can you level up you can would you like to increase your carrying of five drinks
oh he is skilled how about you you can level up how about main courses so we can get a bit better
and then let me guess you're already leveled up because you do so much stop moving you're so fast
I can't get her okay there we go right now she's almost done
congratulations on unlocking events here's how they work click the event click the plus button
choose the event and click to confirm wait for the event date to come
what what does that mean it's a Saturday
oh increases the value for ages 30 times 7
uh 210
yeah what don't mean was it how is that event positive for me is that positive spring
pirates wait was there pirates there I don't even saw that
Maryland the wizard viking theme party pirates prince visit king and queen feast requirement
oh I I do not have an I don't even have enough for the first one regular party I've not even got
enough for a regular party in the fantasy world what's going on stop why are you sad why are you
stop now you're gonna make me mad stop being so sad when I don't why are you so upset
these employees fit increased salary or level up to improve happiness fine
right let's not make her too happy now
speed while carrying sure okay now how do I do this take out window
okay
now hold on a minute don't write me out just yet don't write me out just yet so
how would you do a takeaway window if it's not like at the front of the tavern
are they gonna come around the building they must do
okay hold on build remove wall remove that then like no well close close but no cigar no cigar
um and then bonk and bonk right okay mm-hmm okay hold on a minute don't don't
okay surely don't call me surely um
I've had balls so far should the chef be on the other thing or should I
um I'm trying take out counter you don't have enough coins well maybe I should have enough coins
have you ever thought about that hold on I okay this does not you can like peek in and be like
hmm what is the chef doing hmm why is this a smoking establishment I hope not smoking
you roast don't they all smoke in middle-earth like even Gandalf smokes um but Gandalf wanted
to be a sucker like a hard-boiled sweet type thing instead of smoking but they ended up completely
like redoing the footage or taking it out I think maybe they recorded two versions and
he never got it I was he ended up being a mocha put that in your pipe and smoke it
tonight then he calls me anymore that I'm always having right my procedure's not going up is not
looking good oh no it's waning oh 10% less guests on a reindeer yeah that no that makes sense that
honestly makes sense how do I get a fireplace I want a fireplace I don't ask for much okay just a
little fireplace that's all cheeky bit of fire play oh I found the decoration okay right everyone
weapons out weapons out weapons away so oh shit wait no I was supposed to pay for the other thing
what was I supposed to pay for draft this one 150 sorry I got distracted yes I'm that distracted
hold on 150 150 come on in the money up here 150 150 one more there we go um special okay bang
now what your kitchen is missing a packing table okay packing table where is it where is the rest of
there I assume kitchen is packing table another 150 I don't know that rich fireplace and light
category maybe yes I think we'll get a fire please and then we can be on nice and medieval
here it is please be careful with the blade if the sweet bar maid wants to polish it all
this look cute literally weapons are left at the door we're just a chill thing here we don't
we don't want to cause no bother no issues we don't want any trouble I promise we ain't dropping
the weaves you two just chatting come on they're shattered 800 oh wait was people walking no oh my
god did you see mercy's hand cam stream she made this adorable like cafe thing and it had like
bread on it and it was like four night night for bread and all that it was so cute
well this is cute too feki and me and uh pretz tail not to be confused with the uh
the pokemon now the uh
the pinata from viva pinata filled with fun filled with fun oh my god good much I
really thought this was flying off me did she finish it yes she did finish it in one stream
um she she tweeted it out and she was like how is this supposed to be done for kids in one sitting
me honestly me when i'm doing pop and cooking that was so hard and difficult i did not come out
like as advertised i don't even know how they did that how they made it like that to get it
photographed in the first place because that was insane I think we are going to have to hire a
second director so um I like that the game tells you like hey your kitchen's all messed up hi hi
um how about you can level you up how about you can level you up yeah how about you can
level you up should do so much not yet
that's a fair thing viva pinata for the exposed to safety needs a remaster yeah oh someone commented
on my sonic heroes they were like strongy finishes it for the first time and then they announced like a
sonic and shadow remake or something um i'll move the kitchen into this little nook here
i think that'll be cute i don't want just like a big tavern that's like one
awkward like one big rectangle i like that he's gonna have a little uh nook to cook in
oh right okay let's make the table the table that i need kitchen right so this is the packing
station why i i am packing thank you for asking me tonight uh i assume just shove it there right
and then i will put him away somehow i don't really know how unless i could like do it right now
no he's like stationed here i don't want to like fire him just so i can move this but i don't
exactly want to in the middle of an ego a jimmy raid wait emmy was streaming early today
oh sleepyhead how is she streaming early hi pen files thank you for the redirect in me and ac and
with me that's a redirect sunday clearly hello we're playing oh she had a collab today oh did it
go great i i know i saw the collab did it go good we use giggling we use we use we use a
having a lot of giggling your seat like i don't know how you laugh but it went very well oh i'm
so glad that's so cute she got stream sniped as well that's amazing i'm glad she could experience
it stream sleeping so fun we're just playing a game called tavern master um i am just having
a stroke i do not want to fire him just so i can move this i think i hope i'm gonna have to though
i'm getting a little nervous i'm getting shaky okay um roblox it was not amazing roblox oh you
play roblox oh you're feeling brave you are feeling brave playing roblox my darlin my darlin
that's brave that is brave of you it is no it is really did i accidentally sell that free i think i did
um yeah i wish the chest wasn't so big
i was wanting to have it all i probably shouldn't have even moved that you know that
you know that i shouldn't even eat that oh well oh well i'll have to deal with my consequences of
the moon action whatever whatever it's not a big deal sure start the next one go right i think we
need to hire another maids um you can't just drag the it literally will not it's like telling me it's
like how long how long one hour an hour an hour and all i had to do was this
an hour what uh no i'm raging i'm raging what is that why why did it not occur to me right
i want a big long table for 400 please i can't believe i did that bro
can you just drag it maybe maybe you're right refling you know what why don't you just be the
streamer why are you unhappy again
well i can't level you up can you like relax
i can't believe it roll those ours mommy roll them hard
reflings i'm a raging i cannot believe that i was so
silly in my way so redundant in my thinking right what i need 400 for that big grand table
i'm a smack in the middle and then we'll upgrade decorations and stuff why is wine pause i don't
why are you struggling improving food rating oh no that's no oh let me get someone so you sweet
boys every region you can relieve your rage out on us that accent got me
my little inkling i think inkling silver okay right we will do big old table in the middle
and then it'll just be there until we can buy seats it's just gonna chill there
what oh
huh right now what i get a new one every day
oh get a new one every day oopsie i see she tried dragging the camera i've
finally figured it out i don't know if you guys are taping at being like strutty please
just read this message and i was perfectly ignoring it every time i look over i'm really
good at doing that i feel really bad but i'm really good at like uh accidentally missing
like all the helpful ones so i'm sorry if i ever frustrate you maybe you should take
it the frustration of me instead of me doing it to you for once
oh okay we're definitely gonna need a new waitress
oh we're minus oh no i'm purchases the table okay new waitress question mark right pause pause
pause the tunes if i get a new waitress higher a waitress okay and i assume she serves the
or would it be a chef no can't it be a chef it would be a waitress right uh mood is not
affected by cleaning gets five bucks tips for every food served whoa that's op gets five tips
every serve what can carry five are they the exact same they are alissa or katelyn let's do alissa
uh right that should be it sure and then we'll upgrade the prestige by putting decorations
around like a hard-earned money although i need benches for strut so please think of the seats
one two is this technically in the dark are we gonna be like i don't want to get in the dark
i don't want to sit in the dark i'm scared right we have two waitresses now
is it okay yeah okay the waitresses do this counter as well
right okay okay yes we need two waitresses in order to do this so she packs it there and
then gives it away well what 27 coins for a loaf of bread
bit of an upcharge don't you think the citizens need to eat too you know
i think you can tell the waitresses what they have to do so one can serve food and get this five
bucks tips are we min maxing the real answer right you were the new hire where's the other
other shows right you
you don't do food like at all how about that or take out and then you don't do cleaning at all
but you do food and take out so you work around each other
oh my god we're min maxing on tavern master
oh we're min maxing on tavern master oh we need to replenish the stock replenish the stock
no way we're this good at the game no way that was such a good suggestion
look how much money we have already
we are so good right we will be able to hire a zero soon as well to sing for the patron
uh maybe if i put you not enough money close enough right one candlelight will do it
but we're davern maxing your other one is already ready to level up
you you you i'm no not you i'm we're straight right let's just slow down a minute god
no wonder i can't even play video games i can't even like snipe her please stop being miserable
i'm praying okay that's good can i level you up no almost though you can level up how about
speed in general because you're taking a hot second to go do stuff you are new
why are you feeling why are you doing oh no she's making what is that it's a fruit bowl
i like the wee hands just kind of da da da da over the top of the food to show that she's wrapping it
okay this tavern's starting to look like an actual business now people that's right okay
and then you get a bonus for doing stuff got it right i i'm learning i'm learning okay
uh let me check the stock actually now that i think about it hold on he might be getting low on stock
no don't just buy it all out so i don't have to think about it right what is an event that i can
do 600 water and lemonade for four sure let's do a regular party what tomorrow
sure and then i don't have cheese i don't even have adventurers my research seems to be stuck on
that so finale 19 rare oh wait or again no no we're organizing an event we'll see what it looks
like the motor wait does the waitress have pointy ears she's lucky but we can't tell
i'm like i'm just waiting on standby they're like uh what are we waiting on we're all looking at each
other right now oh did i just bug out the game uh
mate and bug them out a little bit but that's okay i'm like oh well there you go
salaries wax and oil total negative right oh no 20% less guests how's this
oh how about bugged out of the game all the guests for this event have been served you received
have they
have they been right she's not doing anything because i told her not to do drink i'll just
give her a look oh yeah oh actually yeah i should do that i'll just give her a priority to do the
weird things and then same for the other one as well
no wait oh she's about to level up
oh did you level up no you're about to get some xp grow up get some xp now you can level up
nope i missed she's too fearful the game's bugging out i think because i told them not to do it in
the game's like hmm but that's not in my coding please okay up speed while carrying sure
the chef's like damn no one ordering yet that's not my problem uh carry six drinks why not
okay uh huh oh yeah new checks on any lake to find out about fire risk
low risk of fire 26.5 chance per week well i've been very lucky so far
serve only main courses for the whole day hire some musicians i'm working on it i'm
so i got awarded that money by accident because the event definitely
and i don't seem to have anything towards right forget that uh fire police grill no wait it's the
same again right just the adventurers good to golly does the chef have this stuff to make the food
yeah i bought tons of stuff he's full i don't know i don't know if i bugged him out
okay that's a full day he didn't make a single thing
i'm finding that mildly hard to believe that no one or dared anything that's right i clutched it
and now no one's coming in
oh there you go angry customers no
he's just chilling collecting the shit he literally is as well because i'm not sure what to do
okay okay today he wants to cook okay that's fine sure we gave him a day off look it's perfectly
normal to need a break from work okay that's all i'm saying and you could also bring your own
chunk of meat to the tavern the barkeeper will cook it for you they probably would back in the
old day but uh
how dare i be tired i can't believe it i'm shocked either
take it spent his day off watching people at the tavern he wasn't cooking because the girls
weren't getting the order because you put them off the task i think so i took i put the main one
off the task and the other one wasn't having it so balls that up slightly but we can recover right
if we make it if we're at 700 i'll get a barred rotate the barred towards crowd rotate the band
same as premium yeah that sounds right
a fire broken your tavern on floor order your staff to go extinguish and they will do their
best to extinguish click on an employee find closest fire extinguisher and click it use steps
one and two in order to order employees things wait for the fire to go as if the podium that
hasn't even i just got the musician you water no what you water you water there is not enough
buckets i can only do one at a time no no no no come back come back oh you're so brave though
please extinguish and one i will cry some of your furniture burnt in the fire do you want to sell
it all and buy new yes just replace it my patrons no come back come back the fire's been dealt with
well i was gonna say like oh we've been so lucky we've not had any problems
the barred was a pyromaniac in disguise literally his mixtape is fire
i can't believe that the one time i get a thing wait so is he
oh pair date it's not like paramount no it must be paramount you'll be coming
i mean a technical hardening is about floor tail so like is this just you can go all the way up to
what are you get like 2000 per go oh tartan hey oh it's what oh wall texture tartan you're feeling
brave i'm not sure about that one i am uh not so sure to cook this food you have to have a crate
on a fireplace grill we're actually researching that until everyone's ran away because of the fire
you think you need to rehire since it's technically a new podium
you're so right for that i get to pay 50 quid so did that right at the end of the night we're not
right i'm going to buy decorations to get this place look in
medieval eat this stuff yeah i have about a book key
next to the guy yeah
shit there's a lot of money they've got banners what are you random candles
i will put it uh we're just trying to spruce it up the place it's just a wee bit
but rock mobius oh our window how could i forget our one window i just the ambience go up
i mean i guess we'll put the beers behind the bar and then the hooks can go
here and people can hang up their jackets if they want
500 for a bit of wall art oh we got pumpkin for emmy a little pumpkin
is there anywhere to put it not really
how about we just put the pumpkin right in the kitchen there there you go emmy that's your
item oh my god it looks like he's just there your eyes are drawn to him he's just there he's
chilling okay he's having a good time i think we should make the upstairs and have an adventure
section i think i love that ventures i'm about to i'll see what it says about adventures but uh
yeah if it's like serve people food and drinks down here and then upstairs is where the adventures
are gonna go i'll put like a staircase up on this side oh i got research oh christmas miracle
okay we can research ale i'll take that kitchen decoration 14 guests more waitresses oh waitress
uh start next oh no what what happens i have a fire on the same day no emmy's pumpkin oh right
no it's fine what is he taking a freaking keg of water what are you even gonna do with that
it's water just go in the river it's like 20
i need to hire a guard i don't even have enough money
and what
here and sure oh no godfreed from elden ring any film
godfrey salary aren't wait a day chance to defend against low through 100 chance to defend against
high threat zero i need to pimp him out in a costume it's godfrey the grafted exactly literally
i'm getting the elden ring lord to sort him out i'm not having that i'm not having that i'm gonna
absolutely roll them right we'll do ale i'm sure ale right uh oh no they took my lemonade
if you just ask for it you don't have to take it i mean i produce lemonade every day
oh look at him oh it's a zero oh i love the ambience of this tavern oh thank you thank you
how's it going oh you having a lovely day at the castle oh that's fantastic oh you
oh that's good how about takeaway you guys having a wait long i just take away service ridiculous
a little bit yeah a wee bit oh that's three it takes me oh there you go there you go
hey that's right i think we've been fine that is a large fish broth with lemon exactly
okay i'll go back to having a lemonade barrel excuse me and then i will check
oh like i was literally about to say i'm gonna check if we need to restock the food and we do
food's restocked so next is a staircase
i can do that i know how to make a staircase because i okay maybe i need to unlock a staircase
oh i actually have to unlock a staircase can i do anything you are you squiddin me right now
and yeah go thank you for the extended membership all hydration juice i've not hydrates until my
it's since my tea right hydrate
well
there are more requirements than just proceed yes i'm actually gonna buy decor more decoration
i mean i could just plan another lemonade tomorrow why not
yeah i like the pirate event honestly hi to hydrate with those 20 refills purchases
wax an oil musician i think i think we can do it okay
reach 85 guests in today guests to go all the guests for this event have been served they've
not they've arrived but i'm not gonna argue if you must give me money like that i'm not arguing
it's snow me you're arguing with right the guard elisla can level up uh sure speed while
not carrying why not oh you can raise their chances of a getting a higher tip oh okay maybe
i should be doing that on like everyone
uh we're trying our best look everyone's getting served as best we can okay it's not just overnight
right we need 19 more we can do ale and then we're gonna speed run to the staircase but says gold
people and i'm like um no if i raise wait did i finish research in adventures i did right so
i need to purchase something that will enable a thousand adventures table adventures tables
used to hire ventures to go on special missions to get rare ingredients for special food
i guess we'll have to shove over here for now once we have the money
because yeah i don't have staircases to put it upstairs so we're just doing it
i could hear her go it's johnny the quest giver i need one of your strongest potions
wait why are you upset why is everyone wanting so much money
please don't leave though
okay we're not really at max capacity there's not all these butts down on chairs so
curious curious i think we need more butts down on chairs but i'm not are we stuck to the 20 guests
because of the event
but they keep ordering more drinks and stuff so maybe i shouldn't complain too much
and a belt and level up let's increase your tip chance because that seems to be the best so far
make the tables more claustrophobic i love that instruction
and fuck them up right i
everyone just give up everyone gone i think like 11 yeah the tip chance yeah you need a higher tip
chance of you know you're not getting hired until you have a high tip chance that doesn't make no
stop whoa oh i thought it was like a poet it's the musician it's the musician i'm being a silly
oh 150 right i need a thousand i will buy the adventurer's table that is the next thing to do
i used to be an adventurer like you and then i took an arrow to the knee
i'm ready for questing woman oh they're so cute you look so happy in the way you're more
my way the tip chance increases by joining the alert honestly
oh forgive me riefland forgive me for not that i have sinned as i was up working
um send me in i'm ready no my inkling you need to be careful with that sword
you'll poke someone's eye out with it put it down
uh the crate's missing ingredients sorry i wasn't paying attention please i'm just trying
to make money for an adventurer's table please uh right table special no yes okay adventurers
you guys just sit like weirdos in the corner okay now what what happens here
oh protect a wagon oh what it costs like oh wow adventure levels can it
and affects the adventurer's power
oh i researched ill more waitresses and even rare you get these special gifts by organized
events for improvements to bring oh i can't i could only go oh wow i would need to like go
back to go forward i guess we'll start wine and hope that we've been serving the odd fancy
shmancy person uh wait arming for combat should i fetch my long sword i'm scared but i'm ready
make me taking your arrow to my knee oh that's so cute i'm ready we'll miss edwin let's go
let's go adventuring oh dang it oh dang it oh dang it so this is how i get cheese what would
start event okay i don't want to see that don't show me that again do you understand
right event whoa
oh they like come in and strategize
how unique what so they just wait around for a wee job okay by a barrel of ale i agree with this
let me do that i would like to purchase ale please
ale better make some profits that's all i'm saying 500 for ale right i need 10 cheese
to do the wine tasting okay so i will send the adventurers away go get me 10 cheese
go you cannot start an adventure with zeros like that yeah all they use go go get those cheese
literally forget getting the bread i'm ready for the quest they didn't have a little more
what you guys are getting supply gear there's thunder i'm coming back in adventure cancelled
honestly true
oh just say you hate me game i'm trying my best to make it all work
i'm trying i'm trying what doesn't happen on thunder 50 less guests on thunder i mean honestly
i wouldn't want to go in thunder so i felt that um i can be leveled up uh let's do jik pouring
give us faster than pouring time down to the millisecond i'm timing him
which is the nights of the do decahedron table wait what how did you
one two three four five six seven eight nine ten i don't know how you did that so quickly
you're too fast for me i can't keep up stop being miserable good that fix it right hurry with
your ability of making maybe you counted the chairs possibly
can we have a separate room for secret meetings of the reefing society is that what this is should
i make like a little secret like or like maybe and i like pimp it out and make it all nice
well i'm afraid we aren't making much profits today actually this is very true um when i worked
in the cafe if it rained i was secretly like so happy because i knew it meant i would have less
work um so did i get the cheese then
oh i need more i need more decorations around
oh i don't even have any money at all lovely
how am i so low on money what did i do what am i doing wrong
thinking about it we should be able to have one on each tentacle literally eight swords like
slashing around uh i want to invest in the ale because i think the ale would be like
the next like best seller you know i need even more weight more missing from the crate
there stop i'm trying to buy something i like rainy days but that's a really good reason to
like them literally it was like the relief like i'd take the train and like it may have been miserable
like walking in the rain or that but like it felt so good because i knew it meant i didn't
have to do as much work and i could sit on my phone that work and it makes so the thing if you
have a busy day um it makes uh it makes the day go by like incredibly quickly um but you're exhausted
like you're really tired by the end of it however if you have a really slow day you can
kind of like muck about on your phone and like do what you want which is really nice
and like as is that my my boss at my waitress in job and he was like you couldn't have asked for
a better boss you could not have asked i would like to think he would be very proud of me if uh i let
him in on a actually you know i should fucking message him um i think he would be very proud and
before anyone's like mail on stream he he is a homosexual okay relaxed he is a homosexual yes
there are scottish homosexuals please relax it is not that serious um but yes i think i would like
to think that i have learned a lot from him just from through observations and stuff like that
um and
lamal no it's true still mail on stream you know what you're done for i'm sure he would be proud
i'd like uh you learn a lot through observations seriously like some you know people put like
pressure on them oh i don't know anything i don't know better i don't know nothing that i'm like
you learn a lot just by being there you know showing up is half the work is obviously this has
blind sighted viewers before him what because my boss was mail are you sure you he's fucking
50 years old as well please relax please gilf on gilf granddad oh granddad i thought gilf was
girl hey girl grand hey he would fit in with the pin pals at least wait the pin pals are the oldest
i thought it was snowberries have oldest why are we running out of ingredients so quickly please
stop trolling me there goes my my my ale again and the lemonade's about to run out
leaflings start pissing i'm not paying 100 for this get that start pissing i'm no pain for all this
he hates older men no i don't but i don't want anyone being like oh my god
wait why are you sad stop asking for more money you're killing me this business is going under
i'm getting rid of the musician i'm sorry it's like i can i genuinely don't think i can even afford
that extra 50 like i'm trying so hard to buy a bit of ale i'm sorry i'm like no no don't be silly
we're just goofing off and hanging out i'll pay for you moment he's pissing like i'm frying chicken
back here yeah damn right straight into the keg it wasn't that the pin pals are the oldest it's just
they're a bit they're a bit what while strongly being an evil corporation honestly i do right
refills salaries wax and oil musicians right the musicians going out we didn't even be paying for that
i didn't want to be hearing it it seems if we level up the food however we get to charge way more
like that's 32 for a bit of bread the upcharge is rather severe i have to admit
ooh a painting right again we only have 200 no oh
oh you have successfully defended against the thief
i didn't even need to do that
okay that's good i'm happy oh wait wait this is the recipe i need
that's the recipe i need what am i investing in
am i going mental are we even investigating anything no we are wine 15 okay sorry 15 we need 15 more
what in the cream rolls i have to ask after the lemonade let me hold your chicken fryer
all right damn boy you put some you put loudest fuck i'm just kidding though oh wait what's the
damn boy you could it's a rumor hit singer jimmy buzer from popular boy band peeler like to sit in
a chair and watch oh no that's a that's a real no wait hold on a minute no no no i heard that
rumor too kind of real though because it gets you 20 of those you need to 15 of them you need
to hold a party to get the wine but i don't have the requirements i have wait where's the cheese
did the knights not go get cheese give me the fucking cheese right and then i need to unlock
uh that thing to do the wine party the recipe for cheese which is done through goals which is
this one we reach three stars on any food buy a new barrel ale serve only main i don't know what
finish any research i'm trying i'm trying okay okay i can buy a barrel let's do that now ale
ale max refill please give me all the money
they can't be mad that's really good wait why is this special free oh my gosh the aura
let's put it in front of the night well next to the night's table okay the aura has now gone up in
the establishment guess is 20 rare for a regular party wait the first one counts as well are you
sure i think it glitched out because it was like all your things have been served and i'm like you
know what oh am i dumb a little bit but that's the experience you get when you watch someone play
a game for the first time you can't buy the fucking pepper average occupancy oh 90 percent
well start next day go go go surely the number tells you how many more guests will come to you
having oh it is putting my research up unless i'm going mental and i miss it
i need 14 more what no i don't need 14 more they're all here
the pain in hearts most even how high it goes well you don't like the ship
look at the detail look at the the orange look they're up on this pool how dangerous
what's not oh shall i prove what's going on here where is the life draft shocking
shocking behavior
they must be in a lot of m&d supplements i don't know would add in windows raise the thing i just
feel like this is such a dark and dingy tavern like on the front you're like oh maybe the
windows are like on the sides or the back nope it's all walls get right the painting show
the outside world so no need of windows real and true exactly these people don't deserve to see
okay why are you sad
are they gonna quit i don't know if they're gonna quit
i'm feeling rather nervous that they're gonna quit on me
there is no fireplace or other source of heat it must be like a dungeon inside
mommy you look like a tavern yeah try my best what do you mean that's bubbling off of me no
don't take a peek at my hunkers what are you talking i like it you can kind of see
you look the kids need to oh the research is going up why did you so broken why was that so
broken was it that so hard give me another one this event is already being scheduled
give me another another one dammit oh dang it right okay i can't do that but
but i can level up i need the recipe for cheese and then i can do wine i can do wine okay gorgeous
yep salaries 250 and wax and oil okay so that seems to be like the base of like what i need to do
um looking this is the best tavern in town for sure for real yep mm-hmm the green dragon in
even though you cannot sleep here yet because i'm not even unlocked it anywhere nice anywhere nice at all
no for real cap on a stack on g i didn't know on g meant on god for ages and i was like what
is what is anyone saying it's also the only tavern in town ergo the best one thank you even if we
went by a d like a default and then i'll still take it i'm wondering if we should put the kitchen
like right here and then the drink should be elsewhere
hmm curious curious power is a cure buy a new barrel of wine i don't have wine unlocked the game
thinks i have wine unlocked i'm not even there okay i'm just gonna do this so i don't have to think
about uh there everything's refilled so no one can get mad at me anabelle you can level up uh and then
speed sure let's just even out your speed stats you just unlock wine
why am i special and more at four okay wine barrel please someone buy something
three four three five three six three seven can i get three seven in the back
hey can i get three eight way okay uh reeflings ferment some grapes in your mouth right now
i'm trying to refill as best as i can
eight
no one's getting paid tonight it's all going to wine
do i make myself clear uh
we need to go to edgeville for a while oh i never sold those wines that i made
i'll make like pennies back on what was spent on the base but
okay everything is restocked no one can touch me no one can get mad at me
i mean oh and 16 benches i mean what you made to introduce another table total seat average
occupancy i mean 100 guests a day i guess i could i guess i guess i could
serve more than 40 customers in a day well get that have you leveled up any cooking recipes yet
i know i don't think so
i mean strong makes the best one do you want to know where i ferment them
indeed the lack of cheese is disturbing and then it's star wars reference
i find your lack of cheese disturbing that was my Darth Vader i'm sorry i had to be witness to that
okay it seems like the money is in the food if everyone could just be like ravenous for
one day that honestly would be gorgeous i'd be so happy please be as ravenous as you're like
he is pouring them pints that's a lot of drinks
more may have 200 points yeah we're having research what we're looking at now we need seven
rare folk to come in and then we can do drink prices we can take the prices up
reflame right i'm gonna do one of these to get the last of those red guests and that we need
i can miss 700 bucks i'll take it and then we'll do the table okay this is the table
everyone has been forced to sit at these like big ones so i am gonna oh no it says have benches
well i'm just gonna have to do this one
um
i know i know i know i was going to do a wee table but it still happens
okay then we'll make a table for dating medieval presents
box and then just a little one there and one more beautiful that's so cute now you we can
have a little medieval day uh i'll just do on one side i'll let the knights kind of have this corner
why not knock themselves out uh and then i got an achievement for that and i need four more for
this freaking cheese and then i can have the fancy people come in and make all the money
what are we getting there that is a lot of mess to clean up this is very cozy my sleep
under the counter are you tired do you need a little rest under here oh no there's not a whole
bit for you to sleep in um where would i put you to sleep i'd let you use the crate as a pillow
and you could smell all the ingredients inside and then when you get tired you can look at the
glistening like candlelight the way the candle flickers and it will slowly allow you to sleep
oh i need one more point i'm gonna far are you joking
one more point and then i can do my little cheese thing oh we're in the profits today
purchased waxed oil i've got bonuses rewards food soul takeout like takeout is too hot like
it's dabby stop being so sad i'm gonna i'm getting annoyed at you
right can i unlock a goal own 20 benches own 10 tables
i just bought two balls and benches and stuff like that how's the crate looking
okay we'll fill it up no one's ordering meat or anything that's that's gonna go
spoil spoil i'm a very small bug fella not as short as i used to be during my journey in
hallows mind you but i'm sure it's that fit does the tavern have a date with a winch on the menu
uh actually yes somehow i don't know how we to okay we got right uh we did offer that service
but unfortunately the current winches uh being spoken to by another client at the moment please
do excuse um i was gonna say that was fantastic timing but you kind of got sniped a bit there
up tips close up uh speed sure whatever and then up
uh then let's just even out his stats in general because he's got his only kitchen
area no i wanted that open sounds like your villagers are just the tavern master i think
oh we need four more for a fireplace bro i feel like that's going to be a big massive
hazard however which is a shame but we try oh they put the detail of the flies around the light
that's actually really good you wouldn't think they would have bothered with that to be honest
i mean i wouldn't have thought of that i'd be like nope that's a light there you go that's all you're
getting okay can i do any of these own 10 tables fine fine do i even have room for another table
sorry that's just going to be a table for someone who's not very social and then
um sorry to the knights but i'm needing to get some achievement there
there this can be like a mysterious person that sits at this table
and they're always ready for a shocker running okay there we go we have the cheese we can finally
post right i need decorations people decorations get them up get them up on the walls i don't care
what it is what's that barrels with scrolls okay let's pop it in the corner we love a good
decoration who doesn't and then we've got a globe because the knights obviously need to see
what's around the world what's this a random bit on the wall okay that's really gonna spruce up the
place i found the fireplace oh that would look gorgeous oh can i afford it oh no i can't it's
a thousand you don't have enough money no i don't you're actually correct can i agree with you okay
let's do coat of arms classic do i have enough prestige yet or am i going to be crying do i have
enough on prestige surely copy i'm surely i have enough prestige yes oh my god we did it we do the
wine tasting we did it we officially can do the wine tasting prestige go burger literally we can do
the wine tasting oh we can do it we can do it and then we can be awesome and super cool and
everyone loves the green dragon in yes the opening might have been shaky yes we only had two tables
but that wasn't going to stop us from becoming the best uh tavern in town yes we are the only
tavern in town no that does not take away from the fact that we're the best i assure you it's just
a coincidence um but yeah we're doing it we're getting fancy i'm waiting we'll we'll play through
that event we'll see what happened although they call it an event it doesn't seem like much happened
really if i'm being controversial
when are we rebrand rebranding to the green cuttlefish tavern oh this is a Hobbiton though
the brie one is called prancing pony from lord of the ring i think once we introduce the in the
in keep thing like the sleeping mechanic where they can sleep overnight then we turn it into a whole
house we'll we'll change our reputation not only do you get a belly full of meat you also get emptied
in other ways i'm here to appease the people okay sometimes the people just need a good time
uh and that's that's all oh we're out of ingredients we're always out of ingredients
may i take a thagando beneath my ladies froh the waitresses get full of meat too
oh thank you thank you what a lovely tavern audience
oh looking at a swimming stream should be appeasing enough
when we leave we have a full belly and so do the winches
let's do kitchen decoration drink price yeah we're gonna drink right right we're doing it
we finally have the fancy no goi exactly that's what i thought goi i've got an event
you've successfully defended against the thieves oh look at how noble they are with their dresses
and oh he's got all the guests for this event have been served i think that's a bit premature but
we'll take it all the guests have been seated they've not been served maybe it means seated
oh look everyone oh they're all having the wine let's make sure wine reserves are high
reeflings that's right open your mouth i want them i want to see them grapes see them grapes in your
mouth i like how that's the only available area i have to ferment wine it's just your mouth
beautiful stunning look everyone get and serve look at these cups all empty waitress waitress we'd
like more oh waitress even more exactly and no one's ordering food so i guess the chef gets the
day off on event days wait are wow they're peasants here they were looking out oh they're all looking
out the one window and being like wow look at all these peasants look at them peasants all of them
shocking shocking shocking
who did it wine tasting turns to wine drunk pretty damn quick yeah if no one's eating hold on a minute
are you all steaming i think you're needing to go home you're someone's about to spew and i don't
even have a toilet here add denny have a toilet and i think it's about to spew
what's going on here
we did it our wine tasting ritual has complete i'm drunk and i forgot where i live oh you just
come back don't you worry you don't need to go home for the night we'll look after you even though
we're not in wait how did the fruit bowl got leveled up no one's ordering anything
that that's what the bushes outside are for what for people to pass out that's so funny
she's fucking look how much she down one two three four five six seven damn lady you sure can't put
it away okay i'm happy to leave it there if you're happy to leave it there that was the game
called sabron master and i got to play for the first time i am wondering if we come back to it
and we open up the upstairs um i really enjoyed that that was like such a cute little sweet game
all well put together um i found that rather i don't i don't know about you but i do
care i've got rather adorable rather sweet um that's the cutest thing ever i really enjoyed that
maybe we'll come back and we'll we'll make it we'll turn it into a brothel no why are you laughing
no that's not what we're gonna do to oh what are you talking about we'll just roleplay okay
is she be on today or she off today
is she be on today she be is on at 8 am which is like it i was away
it's two hours away that's yes i'm putting you in a waiting room that's two hours away
no i don't care if it's shameless i love you i love to be other girls i want them i want the best
for them i don't care if that means wait a minute it's a room um jimmy stop streaming yes
emi redirected into me emi ac and umi all did it today i'm like dang it was a redirect kind of
trendy um but thank you uh carney rob thank you for the tip as well you didn't put a message on it
pihi but thank you for the super chat oh no it's not super chat the tip thank you for the tip
for this winch thank you for tipping your winches uh
uh the you know redirect literally i was like wait how is emi up because emi's normally four
ish it works after i start toss a coin to your winch yeah
thank you bar wench no no traveler the pleasure was mine next time when you come back we hope
to expand our tavern and also have an inn and i assure you traveler when you're weary and needing
a good rest for a meager five gold coins i can make sure that you feel good by the morning
i tried i tried if we had a roblox fashion club dressed in press she goes streams night
the dress that i'm praying i'll give stranny the tip all right thank you for having a look
forward to next time no thank you um for those of you who are members i'm going to quickly make
a cup of tea and then i'll build up the member stream and it is supposed to be script writing
i'm going to be honest and say it's a yapanan i'm very tired um but i'll be five minutes
before i boot that up but thank you so so much i give you kisses on your face
well i mean wait you tip in the wind oh you tipped me five gold coins i get it now
oh thank you reluctantly say for the five gold oh so just the usual stream then yes
actually exactly five gold coins you see you see it's not about greed it's about the satisfaction
of help it's about the satisfaction of helping everyone sometimes it's better to just let nature
take its course and when a man and a woman get together real force things start to happen i'd be
so happy to be filled with food and meat while being emptied by my favorite bar maid oh i'm getting
close to writing a roleplay hold on a minute because technically technically i wouldn't
need to do anything to my accent because i'm scottish right and people consider that like medieval
right thank you basically whiz uh people consider scottish medieval right so i could just do a bar
maid roleplay and i'll be like uh i'm just the waitress then he mined me fair traveler
absolutely what can i get for you close enough wait we do please do script writing stream is
just about to start so i mean you're not wrong but yes thank you so so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed this cute little game honestly i can't remember how much it was on steam i think there
was a wee bit of a price if it's um definitely um how to say early access and not pot like i mean
it's a cute game for the graphics i feel like maybe it could be i don't mean to be mean though sorry
if the developers watching this right now i really enjoyed your game please don't think i'm being a
beanie um i just feel like yeah there's a lot of discussion going about early access steam games
and being like although i understand it's for developers and indie studios to be able to fund
their game before it comes out because when you buy early access you're being like yeah i want the
finished product at the end of the rainbow and i understand you need funds to do it so i'm buying
this early access thing you know um anyway we can discuss steam early access issues i say that as if
fucking if i'm wanting to get into game dev game publisher publisher piss the one who
puts the money down and asks for the game that's what i want uh right okay thank you so so much
for the stream as i said i'm going to redirect into sheebie which is two hours away so yes we're
going to be redirected into pure silence after this no i will not i will not apologize i love
sheebie i love all of vealer you will support them i demand unity um but thank you so so much i had
fun and we uh might revisit the scene to make the in a section and then once we have made the in section
that's when we know the game is complete the vealer in thank you so so much i'll see you in five
minutes if you're a member if not i'll see you tomorrow for some shoes and gear clothes on i'm
just checking what game i'm playing tomorrow i think it's black ops one campaign it is it's black
ops one campaign let's go denny denny denny denny oh the v suck it in
just so i don't forget when i boot up the game just so i don't forget
wait how much can that type
wait how much can i tell you wait the v suck it in for five gold v stop the food and
no right now shit i was going to ask for scrawny i'll just do that ask for scrawny
okay hold on a minute that just made the game 10 out of 10 i don't care what anyone says
that just made the game 10 out of 10 literally just made it 10 out of 10
that's gorgeous game 10 out of 10 i take it back everything i said adorable love it gorgeous
okay right thank you so so much i give you kisses and i'll see you tomorrow on black ops one
we might play the other cod campaign modes as well a black ops two modern warfare
too as well but we'll see how it goes okay okay now to find a home for my other stuff
oh that's so good it staffs off at the door but not the one attached
oh thank you thank you okay right thank you so much we've learned i'll see you tomorrow
if not i'll see you in five minutes okay i'll go make a cup of tea bye
oh traveler what's this don't be happy to see me
is that treasure are you just happy to see me okay bye
bye
i'm start bit beatboxing on it